in the last video we started with the
star in the in its main sequence like
the Sun and inside the core of that star
you had hydrogen fusion going on so that
is hydrogen fusion and then outside of
the core you just hide hydrogen
you just had hydrogen plasma and we say
plasma it's the electrons and protons of
the individual atoms have been
disassociated because the temperatures
and pressures are so high so they really
just kind of it's like the soup of
electrons and high electrons and protons
as opposed to proper atoms that we
associate with at lower temperatures so
this is a main-sequence star right over
here this is a main-sequence star right
over here and we saw in the last video
that this hydrogen is fusing into helium
so we start having more and more helium
here and as we have more and more helium
the core becomes more and more dense
because helium is a more massive atom
and just be able to pack more mass in a
smaller volume so this gets more and
more dense so core becomes more dense
more dense until at some point and so
what while the core is becoming more and
more dense that actually makes the
fusion happen faster and faster because
it's more dense more gravitational
pressure more mass wanting to get to it
more pressure on the on the hydrogen is
fusing so it starts to fuse hotter so
let me write this so the fusion so
hydrogen fuses fuses faster and actually
we even see this in our Sun our Sun
today is brighter and hotter it's fusing
faster than it was when it was born 4.5
or 4.6 billion years ago but eventually
you're going to get the point so that
the core you only have helium you only
have helium so there's going to be some
point where the entire core is all
helium it's going to be way denser than
this core over here all of that mass
over there has now been turned into
helium not all of it a lot of it has
been turned into energy but most of it
is now in helium it's going to be in a
much much smaller volume and the whole
time the temperature is increasing the
fusion is getting faster and faster and
now
this in this dense volume of heat of
helium that's not fusing you do have and
we saw this video a shell around it a
shell around it of hydrogen that is
fusing so this right here is hydrogen
fusion going on and then this over here
is just hydrogen plasma
now the unintuitive thing or at least
this was unintuitive to me at first was
is the stuff that's going at what's
going on in the core is that the core is
getting more and more dense it's it's
fusing at a faster rate but and so it's
getting hotter and hotter so the core is
hotter fusing faster and getting more
and more dense and I kind of imagine it
starting to collapse every time it
collapses it's getting hotter and more
dense but at the same time that's
happening the star itself is getting
bigger the star itself is getting bigger
and this is actually not drawn to scale
red giants are much much larger than
main sequence stars but the whole time
that this is getting more dense the rest
of the stars you can kind of view it as
getting less dense and that's because
this is generating so much energy that
it's able to it's able to more than
offset or better offset the
gravitational pull in into it so even
though this is hotter it's able to
disperse the rest of the material in the
Sun over a larger volume and so that
volume is so big that the surface and we
saw this in the last video the surface
of the red giant is actually cooler is
actually cooler let me write that a
little neater is actually cooler than
the surface of a main-sequence star this
right here is hotter and just to put
things in perspective if this when the
Sun becomes a red giant and it will
become a red giant its diameter will be
a hundred times the diameter that it is
today or another way to be put it it
will be have the same diameter as the
Earth's orbit around the current Sun or
another way to do this where we are
right now will be on the surface or near
the surface or maybe even inside of that
future Sun or another way to put it when
the Sun becomes a red giant the earths
going to be not even a speck out here
and it will be liquefied and vaporized
at
point-in-time so this is super super
huge and we've even thought about it
just for light to reach the current Sun
to our point in orbit it takes 8 minutes
so that's how far that's how big one of
these stars are to get from the to get
from the one side of the star to another
side of the star
it'll take 16 minutes for light light to
travel if it was traveling that diameter
and even slightly longer if it was a
travel it'd go in a circumference so
these are huge huge huge stars and we'll
talk about other stars in the future
they're even bigger than this when they
become super Giants but anyway we have
the huge hydrogen in the center we've
now become sorry we have the helium in
the center let me write this down we
have a helium core in the center helium
core in the center we're fusing faster
and faster and faster we're now a red
giant the core is getting hotter and
hotter and hotter until it gets to the
temperature for ignition of helium so
until it gets to 100 million Kelvin
remember the ignition temperature for
hydrogen was 10 million Kelvin so now
we're at a hundred million Kelvin factor
of 10 and now all of a sudden in the
core you actually start to have helium
fusion helium fusion and we touched on
this in the last video but the helium is
fusing into heavier elements and some of
those heavier elements and predominantly
it will be carbon and oxygen carbon and
oxygen and you may suspect this is how
heavier and heavier elements form in the
universe they form literally due to
fusion in the core of stars this but
especially well especially when we're
talking about elements up to iron but
anyway we have the core now is now
experiencing helium fusion it has a
shell around it of helium that is not
quite there does not quite have the
pressures and temperatures to fuse yet
so just regular helium but then outside
of that we do have the pressures and
temperatures for hydrogen for hydrogen
to continue to fuse so out here you do
have hydrogen fusion you do have
hydrogen fusion and then over and then
outside over here you just have the
regular hydrogen plasma so what just
happened here when you have helium
fusion all set
now this is once again providing some
type of energetic support outward
support for the core so you're going to
it's going to counteract the the ever
increasing contraction of the cores it
gets more and more dense because now we
have energy we have energy going outward
energy pushing things outward but at the
same time at the at the same time that
that is happening more and more hydrogen
in this layer is turning into helium is
fusing into helium so it's making this
inert part of the helium core even
larger and larger denser and even larger
and larger and putting even more
pressure on this inside part and so
what's actually going to happen within a
few moments from I guess especially from
a cosmological point of view this helium
fusion is going to be it's going to be
burning super I shouldn't use igniting
or fusing in a super hot level but it's
contained do all of this pressure but at
some point that pressure won't be able
to contain it and the core is going to
explode but it's not going to be one of
these catastrophic explosions where the
star is going to be destroyed it's just
going to release a lot of energy all of
a sudden into the star and that's called
a helium flash a helium flash but once
that happens all of a sudden then now
the star is going to be more stable and
I use that in in and I'll use that in
quotes without writing it down because
red giants in general are already
getting to be less stable than a
main-sequence star but once that happens
you now will have a slightly larger
volume so it's not being contained in as
small of a tight volume that helium
flash kind of took care of that so now
you have helium fusing into carbon and
oxygen and there's all sorts of other
combinations of things obviously there's
many elements in between helium and
carbon and oxygen but these are the ones
that dominate and then outside of that
you have the Healey you have you have
you have helium forming you have helium
that is not fusing and then outside of
that you have your your fusing hydrogen
you have over here you have hydrogen
fusing into helium and then out here and
the rest of the radius of our super huge
red giant you
just have you just have your hydrogen
plasma out here now what's going to
happen as the star ages well if we
fast-forward this a bunch and remember
as a star gets denser and denser in the
core and the reactions happen faster and
faster this core is expelling more and
more energy out where the star keeps
growing and the surface gets cooler and
cooler so if we fast forward a bunch and
this is what's going to happen to
something the mass of our Sun if here's
more massive then at some point the core
of that of carbon and oxygen is forming
can start to fuse into even heavier
elements but in the case of the Sun it
will never get to that 600 million
Kelvin to actually fuse the carbon and
the oxygen and so you'll have eventually
you will have a core of carbon and
oxygen or mainly carbon and oxygen
surrounded by surrounded by fusing
helium surrounded by fusing helium
surrounded by non fusing helium
surrounded by fusing hydrogen surrounded
by fusing hydrogen which is surrounded
by non fusing hydrogen or just a
hydrogen plasma of the Sun but
eventually all of this fuel will run out
all of the hydrogen will run out in the
stars all of this hydrogen all of this
fusing hydrogen will run out all of this
fusion helium will run out all of this
is the olive this is the fusing hydrogen
this is the inert helium which will run
out will be used in kind of this core
being fused into the carbon and oxygen
until you get to a point where you
literally where you literally just have
a really hot core of carbon and oxygen
and it's super dense this whole time it
will be getting more and more dense as
more heavier and heavier elements show
up in the core so it gets denser and
denser and denser but the super dense
thing will not in the case of the Sun
and it was a more massive star it would
get there but in the case of the Sun it
will not get hot enough for the carbon
and the oxygen to form so it really will
just be this dense ball of carbon super
dense ball of carbon and oxygen and all
of the other material in the Sun
remember was super energetic it was
releasing tons and tons of energy the
more that we progressed down this the
more
was releasing outward and the larger the
radius of the star game and the cooler
the outside of the star became until the
outside just becomes this kind of cloud
of this huge cloud of gas and and around
what once was the star and in the center
so I could just draw it as this huge
this is now way far away from the star
much even bigger than the radius or the
diameter of a red giant and all we'll
have left is is a mass a super dense
mass of I would call it inert inert
carbon or oxygen this will is in the
case of the Sun and at first when it's
hot and it will be releasing radiation
because it's so hot we'll call this a
white dwarf this right here is called a
white dwarf and it'll cool down over
many many many many many many many years
until it becomes when it's no longer was
completely cooled down lost all of its
energy it'll just be the super dense
ball of carbon and oxygen at which point
we would call it a we would call it a
black dwarf a black dwarf and these are
obviously very hard to observe because
they're not emitting light and they
don't have kind of the they don't have
quite the mass of something like a black
hole that isn't even emitting light but
you can see how it's affecting things
around it so that's what's going to
happen to the Sun in the next few videos
we're going to talk about what would
happen to things less massive than the
Sun and what would happen to things more
massive the Sun although I think you can
imagine the more massive these the
carbon then this there would be so much
pressure on these things because you
have so much mass around it that these
would begin to fuse into heavier and
heavier elements until we get to iron